Julieta está trabajando en un reporte escolar
utilizando un procesador de palabras. Ella quiere
poner una figura que tiene 13.09 centímetros de
ancho de manera que quede centrada en la página.
El ancho de la página es de 21.59 centímetros.
¿Cuánto margen debe de dejar a la izquierda para
que la figura quede centrada? A ver, veamos lo que
tenemos, nos están diciendo que tenemos un papel
de 21.59 cm, que es lo que vamos a dibujar
aquí. Ahora vamos a poner el papel en que
normalmente lo ponemos en blanco, las
hojas de papel normalmente son blancas.
A ver, más o menos así está mi papel, además
este es un tamaño de papel pues muy común,
ahora voy a poner la figura, digamos que la figura
la vamos a poner en magenta, y más o menos para
que quede centrada, más o menos se vería así
como lo estamos poniendo. Entonces, lo que yo
quiero saber... A perdón, pero esta, la figura,
ésta tiene una, un ancho de 13.09 cm. Muy bien,
entonces, para que la figura quede centrada, lo
que yo tengo que hacer es que, esta distancia
que está aquí, que es el margen izquierdo, que es
el que no conozco, sea exactamente igual a esta
distancia que está acá, que es el margen derecho;
si estas dos distancias son iguales, entonces la
figura quedará centrada. ¿Y qué es lo que tengo
que hacer? Bien, pues lo que yo conozco es que mi
papel es de 21.59 cm, y si yo restara de estos
21.59 el ancho de la figura, o sea los 13.09,
si yo restara de 21.59 13.09, entonces
obtendría la suma de estas dos distancias, ¿sí?,
esta, el margen izquierdo y el margen
derecho. Y después, si yo tomara esa
distancia y la dividiera entre 2 obtendría
exactamente esta distancia que estoy buscando.
21.59 - 13.09 es exactamente
8.50 centímetros. Y ahora,
si yo dividirá entre 2, y otra forma de verlo
es si yo multiplicara esto por 1/2 o 0.5 -da
lo mismo-, voy a obtener la distancia que estoy
buscando. Entonces, ¿cuál es la mitad de 8.5?
Bueno, pues la mitad de 8.5 es 4.25 centímetros,
y ya tenemos el dato que estábamos buscando:
el margen izquierdo tendrá que ser de 4.25
centímetros y obviamente esta distancia de
este lado también será de 4.25 centímetros.
Y podemos observar que si sumo 4.25 con 4.25
obtengo los 8. 50 centímetros, que si a eso le
sumo 13.09 obtenemos el ancho de todo el papel.